hey everybody its charlie thanks
everybody for leaving all those awesome
questions on my worrying video
lots of people hoping for some some very
big WTF moments in season 6 and there's
been a lot of Awesome evidence from this
set that Artie's gonna be doing some
awesome stuff I don't know how close
she'll get to the things that she does
in the books but she'll definitely be
doing at least one big book storyline
but just careful for spoilers as we get
into questions so here we go number one
Tucker asks maybe John Ward into ghosts
before he died and he can control his
corpse like White Walkers control the
whites so just to clear up how work he
works our skin changing works if
someone's skin changes into someone else
or to an animal eventually that animals
consciousness will take over if the
original host body dies like if John's
body really did die then he would cease
to be John after a certain period of
time like he wouldn't exist anymore so I
don't think that the show would do
something like that it just seems silly
to have some other character pretend to
be John to pretend to act as John and
then stop being fake John and being the
regular character again after a certain
period of time like if he were to war
against a ghost yes he would be John
snow inside ghosts body for a short
period of time but then the minute that
his original body died there'd be like a
ticking clock and then after like an
episode or two he'd be full ghost again
the only way for a warg or a
skin-changer to experience death and
survive is if the body that they worked
into dies while their original host body
is still alive and it's incredibly
traumatic next question silence ask I
hope REOC again I mean with her face I
don't want her to forget about the list
and the people she's trying to kill no I
definitely don't think that she's are
gonna forget about that I do think that
the show will have a creative workaround
to her getting her sight back
but it's a manufactured thing it's like
a punitive thing that the faceless men
did to her she'll definitely get her
sight back though the real question is
is how long will she go before she gets
it back a lot of you guys pointed out
how this happens in the books I don't
know that the show's gonna do the exact
same thing that the books did with Arya
storyline like I said in last night's
video I think that they'll be doing the
Mersey chapter the george RR martin
posted online or it's not a full chapter
it's just an excerpt but it's from winds
of winter beyond that I don't know how
close she'll get to the books if you
want to read the books just read Dance
with Dragons it'll tell you exactly what
everyone's talking about when they talk
about Arya singing again you know quote
unquote next question Hannah asks is the
iron bank ever going to become a
significant
this storyline or one of the story lines
so you're saying like you know will they
ever be on screen for more than one
episode like they were real just a small
part of season 5 yes I definitely think
that will come back to haunt the crown
at a certain point in the books the iron
bank is just a much bigger presence
there are more characters associated
with the iron bank storyline Stannis has
to keep getting loans but remember
Stannis is still alive in the books so
it seems like most of the iron banks
storyline on the show will be tied to
the crown in its debts but you remember
the whole reason that mace Tyrell went
to Braavos was to get an extension on
the loan or just to get more favorable
terms so it seems like they're just kind
of pushing them off into the distance
for a lot of seasons sakes I'm not
expecting a ton of iron bank stuff in
season 6 what I think will end up
happening is is that both on the show
and in the books the iron bank will just
get so pissed off at all the people that
owe the money in Westeros that they'll
turn around and support Daenerys
better have my money
next question wu asks i'm not even sure
how to say that Wu do you think that
Jorah Mormont will get his greyscale
cured like Shireen I'm actually kind of
hoping that he doesn't I want him to be
a tragic hero like someone who tries to
redeem himself but knows that he's going
to die so he tries to help out anyway if
there was ever anything the show could
do to punch you in the fields it would
be to have Jorah Mormont do something
really heroic knowing that he's going to
die but just looking at the progression
of greyscale I think that he has to
almost the end of the series just based
on the rate of spread but a lot of that
will depend on what he looks like when
we see him in season 6 usually new
seasons of the show pick up immediately
after the finales of the previous season
so I don't think a whole lot of time
will have passed when we get to season 6
episode 1 so I'm not expecting crazy
greyscale like all over his body or
anything like that but if you haven't
read the books there's a year on
Victarion storyline where some greyscale
gets cured in a really interesting way
so that I mean that could be the
solution for Jorah Mormont now that I
think about it that would be pretty
badass on screen too but but I think
somatically I mean just just looking at
his entire arc over the entire series
I'd like to see him go down being a
tragic hero I think I think that would
be more rewarding next question Korhal
asks do you think that next season the
show will advance Littlefinger's plot
towards the north
do you have any predictions on how that
might play out well Littlefinger the
weird thing about the show is is that
the producers said that Littlefinger
doesn't know about Ramsay Bolton so that
you know everyone was kind of shaking
their fist in the air
so I think he'll try and scramble in
back the North remembers plotline like
if he finds out that a bunch of northern
Lords are rallying against the Bolton's
he'll probably try and help them out and
benefit from it
remember he still controls the veil so
what he's probably gonna try and do is
form an alliance between the Vale in the
other northern Lords to get rid of the
Bolton's that's kind of Littlefinger's
things sit back and see where the
hits the fan and find a way to benefit
from it so he's gonna try and play the
kingdom against the Bolton's and play
the Bolton's against the Lannisters in
the crown next question tatewaki
you explain what would happen if John
really is dead no one ever theorized
about it so this is actually this is fun
I mean I don't think that he's dead but
if he were dead what would probably
happen is is Sansa would be like the
go-to person for saving the north really
what's at stake is pacifying the north
and then dealing with the White Walkers
- on top of that like one has to come
before the other
Sansa's storyline seems like it's
pushing her in a more political
direction just getting better at playing
the game of Thrones you know so to speak
almost as if she were becoming a
Littlefinger type character just you
know better at playing with words than
with swords so in the scenario where Jon
dies the story just starts to rally
around her as a more important figure to
the north and she becomes the one to
broker an alliance with Daenerys
whenever Daenerys comes to Westeros and
they need to fight White Walkers because
no matter what Daenerys is coming to
Westeros eventually with her army so
somebody is going to have to form an
alliance with her against the White
Walkers and right now it's seen it seems
like it might end up being Jon Snow just
because he's really good at dealing with
a bunch of different groups of people
but that's something that as a
politician Sansa could also do so that's
just all speculation but I do think that
Sansa will continue to be very important
regardless of what happens at Jon Snow
if anyone is gonna be left to rule
Winterfell after season eight is done
it's gonna be Sansa next question dark
dark lighting s here's the theory that
what if in the past the Starks made a
Blood Pact with the children of the
forest so you're talking I'm not exactly
sure what you're referring to maybe
working specifically I do think that
it's possible that the children of the
forest taught the first men about
working I don't know if there was any
intermarriage or anything like that but
there actually was a real pact between
the first men and the children of the
forest the thing is is they had their
own war before the Andals invaded so
eventually they reached a truce
the children of the forest retreated to
the forest the first men took the rest
of Westeros and that was all before the
Andals invaded and then the Andals and
the first men had their own war next
question
Riley asks I'd like to see a bonus video
about Dothraki origins
well we actually we know a little bit
about the origins from world of Ice and
Fire if you haven't read that book is
actually pretty cool their ancestors
migrated from this huge mountain range
of the Far East so what happened is is
way over here in what's called the Bohn
Mountains their ancestors ended up
leaving migrating into what became the
Dothraki sea and eventually they grew to
the migratory culture that they have
right now there isn't a super precise
timeline on when that all happened but
it did happen a long time before the
rise and doom of Valyria you have to
remember that et over here like in the
far east some of these Far Eastern
cultures were a huge way before the
Valerians ever domesticated dragons next
question Sophia asks any thoughts on the
casting for the new euron greyjoy the
guy that they chose was not what I
expected
yeah he definitely I mean he's not a
very well known international actor but
in Europe he's actually a pretty big
deal I'm not super familiar with his
work but I totally trust the game of
thrones casting directors they actually
just cast Richard II grant - there's
still a couple big characters that
they're casting so we don't know who
he's playing yet but they have crazy
money to get awesome actors and because
they only film ten episodes a year it's
a lot easier to get some of the bigger
actors that do a lot of film work I've
already spent so much time talking about
you're on Greyjoy that I really didn't
think I needed to do a new video on him
I do think we'll see a small version of
the Kingsmoot but I think a lot of
people saw the actor that they cast and
they're like oh well you know since this
isn't like the biggest actor in the
history of the universe does that mean
that you're on Greyjoy's storyline isn't
as big as we think it's gonna be in the
books all I'll say is that you're on is
a very important character but I don't
think that there are any characters on
the show right now that they'll cast
that will be more important than the
original main cast from season one like
look at the characters that we meet in
the pilot these are gonna be the most
important characters in the series
finale early at least the ones that
survived - the series finale so even if
the game of thrones casting director
resurrects Laurence Olivier's corpse and
cast him as a huge character like
Rhaegar Targaryen or someone like that
on the TV show he's not going to be more
important than the cast from the pilot
typically that's the way a lot of
narratives work it's just you meet
the most important people in the first
book in the first episode it lays all
the groundwork that you need to theorize
about how the story's gonna end so I am
really excited about your on Greyjoy but
I mean no I don't think that he's gonna
be more important than Arya Stark or
Sansa or Jon Snow or any of the
Lannisters next question
my one room disco asks do you think the
children of the forest played a role in
the creation of the White Walkers that's
a really interesting thought based on
the way that they've reproduced it seems
like their creation was an unnatural
thing like they're a man-made phenomenon
the weird thing about them is that
George R Martin has said that he doesn't
know if they have a culture yet like as
it is if he hasn't written it yet and if
you weren't sure obviously he has a lot
of ideas about how he wants the story to
end but he does make up a lot of things
as he goes along what I'd like to see is
that their culture just evolved
naturally over time but they lost the
ability to reproduce as far as we know
they're every bit as old as the children
of the forest but there's just so much
we don't know about the history of the
world that it's hard to speculate so I
think we'll have to wait till after wins
a winner that says you could question to
end on for you guys how do you think
that the White Walkers culture evolved
like where did they come from and how
did they lose the ability to reproduce
or or did they ever have the ability to
reproduce there had to have been a first
white Walker at some point or a more
normal humanoid that was twisted by
magic but thank you so much everyone for
so many questions these are always a ton
of fun to do there is new Walking Dead
next week so there will be more Walking
Dead next Sunday it was just on break
for Labor Day this week congratulations
to this week's giveaway winner
underappreciated Ice Bear you win a $20
Amazon gift card just be sure to message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact info Ice Bear maybe
you could tell us how the White Walkers
got started we're still about another
week away from a couple of TV shows
coming back but there are a couple
trailers like there's a flash trailer
that I think is gonna drop this week so
just stay tuned for that if you guys
want you can follow me on Twitter and
Facebook for updates on videos that are
coming the links with that are down in
the description and also links for a
couple of specific bonus videos so
everybody enjoy the rest of your Labor
Day while you wait for my next video to
post you can click here to learn all
about Ozora hi and the night's king and
you can click here for all the latest
trailers that I've been posting thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you